this is third album and congratulations
on your third baby yeah amazing is that
how it's going to go from now on just
gonna clear we got a new album new baby
yes one of the reasons why labels don't
like us because every time we want to
put out an album I end up having a baby
and they're like but how's this gonna
work
yeah then we pretty good run how did you
guys meet and how did that happen
Wow we were honored the otherwise to
film yeah and he was playing soccer and
I was just so impressed with his soccer
skill I was like wow no we just were
from the same town and me and we played
in different bands and I just started
working together on projects because I
think you know we were both very
passionate about what we did one of
those passions as the group's new EP
Taekwondo the soundtrack and the
coinciding short film they produced and
directly
[Music]
but the project wasn't loved by all walk
off the Earth's original record label
Sony Music one of the Bands have
scrapped the project as it was too pop
sound instead the group scrapped a label
inking a new deal with Universal Music
Canada
I reckon lay both the time they're like
well you guys don't do that you do this
so that's kind of where it stemmed off
we're like we just have to do this
ourselves we never wanted to be
pigeonholed as like a specific genre or
this type of band or that type of band
we always wanted the freedom to do
whatever we wanted and and you know this
project is just another step towards
that taking my condo I'm gonna kick you
with my toe I now have it stuck in my
head it's a call to action to stand up
for your loved one but if you need to
pacifically do it with your toe
call it in the hero launch together with
in every man